T
ACCEPTABLE.
DAN: JOINING ME NOW IS ONE OF
THE BEST CANDIDATES TUDOR DIXON.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THIS
CLOWN COLBERT AND HIS SO-CALLED
APOLOGY.
>> OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT GENUINE.
BUT I KIND OF LOVE IT.
IT'S HOW THEY ARE TREATING
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
DEMOCRAT ELITISTS ARE COMING OUT
SAYING YOUR CONCERNS ARE NOT
REAL.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE WAS
TRYING TO SAY.
HE SAID I WANT OUR KIDS TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND GO BACK TO THE
BASICS.
GETTING BACK TO READING,
WRITING, MATH.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN WRITTEN OFF.
I THINK IT'S FANTASTIC TO SEE
THAT NOW THEY ARE OPENLY SAYING
THESE PEOPLE DON'T EXIST.
THEY ARE SAYING THE CONCERNS OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DON'T MATTER
BECAUSE WE ARE SAYING WE HEAR
YOU, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE CARE
OF THIS.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE OUR
KIDS ARE EDUCATED, THAT THEY ARE
LEARNING HOW TO READ AND WE ARE
GETTING THE WOKE STUFF OUT OF
OUR SCHOOLS.
DAN: YOU HAVE BEEN OUTSPENT
DRASTICALLY BY GRETCHEN WHITMER.
YET YOUR RACE IS A TOSSUP.
BUT A LOT OF THE POLLS OUT THERE
SHOW WHITE SUBURBAN WOMEN MOVING
IN DROVES OVER TO OUR PARTY, THE
PARTY OF FREEDOM IN THE GOP.
THEY ARE PARENTS, TOO, THEY ARE
TIRED OF BEING IGNORED.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND WE HAVE BEEN OUTSPENT.
SHE SPENT TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON THIS RACE.
ANYBODY WHO WANTS TO HELP OUT ON
OUR SIDE IT'S TudorDixon.com.
WE TAKE TWO STEPS FORWARD AND
THEY ARE HANDING US FIVE MORE
STEPS.
IT GAVE ME NAME RECOGNITION I
COULDN'T AFFORD TO PAY FOR.
NOW THE PARENTS SAYING OUR KIDS
GOT LOCKED OUT OF SCHOOL, THEY
MISSED PROM AND GRADUATION.
NOW THEY ARE BEHIND.
TUDOR DIXON IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HELP US GET OUR KIDS BACK ON
TRACK.
I AM THE MOM OF FOUR KIDS.
AND I COME FROM THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR AND I
WORKED IN A STEEL FOUNDRY MOST
OF MY LIFE.
THEY UNDERSTAND WHITMER'S
ADMINISTRATION HAS GONE OFF
BUSINESS.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE ECONOMIC
ISSUES IN THE STATE OF MICHIGAN
AND THE EDUCATION ISSUES.
I KNOW HOW TO BRING MICHIGAN
BACK.
THE SUBURBAN MOMS ARE REALIZING
I'M THERE FOR THEM 100%.
IT'S TIME FOR GRETCHEN WHITMER
TO RETIRE.
SHE HAS HAD 20 YEARS.
SHE HASN'T FIXED ANY OF THE
PROBLEMS IN MICHIGAN.
SHE MADE THEM WORSE.
PLEADS GO OUT AND VOTE BECAUSE
IT'S SO IMPORTANT THAT WE BRING
BACK OUR FREEDOM AND LIBERTY.
CHECK THIS OUT.
>> I READ A POLL JUST YESTERDAY
THAT WHITE REPUBLICAN SUBURBAN
WOMEN ARE NOW GOING TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
>> WHY?
>> IT'S ALMOST LIKE ROACHES
VOTING FOR RAID.
RIGHT?
DAN: ROACHES VOTING FOR RAID.
KINDS OF DISGUSTING.
>> THIS IS THE DEPLORABLES
MOMENT OF 2016.
IT WILL DRIVE MORE PEOPLE TO THE
POLLS.
THEY WON'T TALK ABOUT IT.
IT WILL THE BE A SHOCK COMES